[Music]
samuels with us in houston hey samuel
what's up
hey dave hey john thank y'all for
everything you do and so far to talk to
you sure what's up
uh two years ago i had a good paying job
a family three kids a house and
no debt and about ten thousand dollars
in savings or so
around that same time i went through a
very bad divorce
had to resign for my job to care for my
three kids that i have full custody over
uh we had to relocate i live now in your
family and so things are better and over
the last six months i've got myself
you know back to where things are you
know no one's starving bills are paid
etc
during that period i
very very foolishly uh borrowed quite a
bit of money
and now i'm in the hole and the my
question for y'all pertains to two
particular uh personal loans through
lending club amounting roughly to about
fifteen thousand dollars um the interest
rate on those to both those loans
let me stop you i want to make sure that
everyone hears real clearly what you
just said lending club was not a
blessing
no okay make sure i understood that okay
because they're so sweet they're so
sweet i mean like sofi right they've got
all these little sweet people doing
little dances in their commercials and
crap
and then when you actually talk to their
customers they go they screwed me
so just to make sure everybody loud and
clear i want to put names with that okay
now so you got fifteen thousand dollars
in debt and your income went before all
hell broke loose in your life was what
it was uh fifty thousand dollars a year
uh i'm actually thirty thousand dollars
in debt and that is at a thirty thirty
five percent interest rate um it goes up
every day i made a plan yesterday to pay
it all off uh by may of next year called
them to walk through it and found out
that my projections were wrong because
uh today if i were to pay them a day i'd
be paying them thirty thousand dollars
if i pay them
what did you say you used to make
50 000 a year and what do you make now
um
i'll be lucky if i make 25 right now
okay
uh what did you used to do sir
i was a music director
um a church musician and um i the the
gig i was in was particularly sweet i
got in there through some major
connections it wasn't no it really
wasn't
fifty thousand dollars a year doesn't
fall in the bucket of particularly sweet
it's okay it's great but
sure 500 000 a year falls under the head
of ending a particularly sweet so um
so what you you know what you've got
really dude is two things you have a
structure problem with the debt
and the second thing is with having the
hell beat out of you for the last three
years you've kind of stopped believing
in you
yeah
i remember that feeling when i went
broke it took me a little while to start
believing in me again
from the trauma
is that okay
yeah that's okay yeah because there's a
bazillion jobs out there right now that
pay more than the stinky one you've got
uh dave if you don't mind my putting
this out there i that i'm currently
working two jobs and right now it keeps
us afloat and my obligations to my
children i mean everything is working
it's just the debt that's killing now
the reason the debt is killing you is
you don't make any money
yes that's true if we can double your
income this problem goes away very
quickly and we really should be able to
without destroying your family life but
you're white knuckling trying to make
math work that doesn't work
yeah and it's that's why you called
because it's not working it's blowing
your brains up right i mean you're just
like you're scrambled eggs
and so i remember this feeling it's
stress induced
so uh anyway
let me let let me step back a second and
but number one i'm going to tell you
that what i'm going to do is go apply
for 10 credit cards and get five of them
and move this debt from freaking lending
tree which now it sounds more like a
payday lender the way they're screwing
you over you've got to get this off of
their books and move it somewhere else
where it's more of a normal if you had
an 18 credit card debt it's be superior
to what you got now
it really would
so let's go get some credit cards and
then i'm going to send you a copy of ken
coleman's book i'm running out of time
john i'm sorry but um wish we had more
time with him
paycheck to purpose dude you've got to
work on the income side of your equation
you've got to believe in you enough
again to go get better jobs